what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch the movie Friday
first time watching for both myself and
of course salamander the Sally La Monaco
Sally how are you my dear I'm great good this is
good rapport right here solid solid opening back
and forth we have accomplished our goals today
you've never even really heard of this movie
before right no I had to Google it when you told
me at first I thought you meant Friday the 13th I
was like did you forget to write the rest so I'm
excited yeah I've never seen it a mid 90s comedy
uh it's been recommended a bunch it's a hard
R and uh YouTube has been uh you know really
they've been delicate lately very very sensitive
folks so uh if things have to be you know a little
bit censored please understand why we have to do
it leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
uh subscribe and click that Bell for any other
movie reactions we got up here on the channel so
I was recovering movies again with us as of late
because she lives in the NYC follow Sally on her
own uh YouTube channel as well I've been putting
the wrong Link in the description box apparently
all this time and lastly full interaction watch
along as we sing it with your own copy of Friday
available for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page along with a bunch of other things that we
covered exclusively over there all right
Sally you ready you ready to do this ready
ready so excited ready for me to hit play on
Netflix all right let's do it let's do it okay
I know you don't smoke weed I know this but
I'm gonna get you high today cause it's Friday
you ain't got no job and you ain't got [__]
to do he's talking to me Fridays I love that
our Fridays when you lived out here
in California oh my God they were
I love that we're covering this
that looks like our neighborhood
I wonder if this is right when Ice Cube started
getting into acting I don't really know the
history of Ice Cube too well I don't either
because this came out when I was born so oh gotcha
it's great oh I love them both
Wayne's brother's show give me the 2p special lots
of hot sauce and all the fries you can give me
foreign
a great thing to dream about I know
he'll be so disappointed when he wakes up
good morning are you prepared for Jehovah's return
because if you're not I have a panther well you
laughs
ain't nothing in this house
every time I come in the
kitchen you in the kitchen
didn't I tell you to take out the picture
fell asleep I wish you were sleeping right
now I'll knock you upside your head with a
left foot make your ass break up and take
out that damn trash what are you doing I'm
throwing this away we ain't even got no milk
you better put some water on that damn [__] it
all right there's some water on that damn [__]
I don't know in the back room
oh no oh man I'll wait till you come Out Boy
bring your ass off up in here would you tell me
you wait till I come on I smelled your [__]
with 22 years now you can't smell my mouth
now your mama told me what happened to you
yesterday how the hell you gonna get fired
on your day off I don't know you need to
trade take a look at that paper over there
got to counter there oh my God
I ain't trying to be no dog catcher why not I
don't even like dogs that's the beauty of it
I grab a dog and I took him you're
not I kicked the [__] out of him and
I believe on my foot up a dog's ass
who would marry this guy he'd be surprised
I didn't go to the show last night
it's a lie ain't nobody
lying I didn't go to the show
went to the show I don't know why are you
messing with that little fast ass girl anyway
now that other girl Debbie she's in school she
has all her teeth she has all her teeth you know
what your problem is you have no game what you
know about gang I know your father He Got Game
don't nobody go in the bathroom
for about 35 45 minutes
you better watch when do you climbing that
food before you get blasted on with what yeah
you ain't the man with this oh my God
you still ain't so that weed smoke cause
I broke these days I don't think you applying
yourself Smokey huh you smoking my [__] hell
no why would I do some [__] like that
I'm gonna have to [__] you up smoking
playing with my money is
like playing with my emotions
I went in there pick up my check came home
supervisor called me about four o'clock talking
about they got me on video tape stealing boxes
you doing stealing boxes for
you trying to build a clubhouse
oh God damn man look
oh wow
who is she
what you doing up so early you know
that Diva don't have this bike for
like three weeks right right I won give
me my money you what hello I lost you
want me to ask for my bike back you know
I wouldn't trip that bike it's right here
it's just like it's both ours
it's like it's both parts
oh yeah
you got knocked up interestingly edited movie
excuse me what could y'all
stay out for grass please
Smokey I need you to go to the store and
give me some cigarettes give me the money
make it enough
foreign
oh my God
damn I knocked the dust off Deadpool wow a lot
of parking in there right man oh
she know what she doing with them
little ass shorts on but you know we be looking
make sure if you leave you lock
up the house and answer the phone
the cable people are supposed to go all right
look at her now she's gonna be ashamed of
herself coming out looking like that hey girl
all right I'm on my way to work call me when you
get home okay man ain't nothing wrong with smoking
weed weed is from the Earth God put this here
for me and you take advantage man take advantage
that is a lot oh that's my song
this is Michael Jackson dancing
what probably smoke bud too how you
doing brother Craig how you doing
I'm all right we call it sentencing
in sin we're around here but team
Normandy and Weston we call this
here a little twinning twin twins
a little bit from my cataract you didn't
put in on this man you better get a
receipt my brother look look look
she bending over clawed hammers so
thank you ohm said you'll take it easy yes sir
oh no it's Angel though slide it real hard right
next thing I know I was running down
the street in my damn drop oh my god
get on me I'm in Debo pigeon
coop sweating like a slave
and the only person could get me out with my mom
don't let me get you boys
y'all can't see me huh it's actually
a really well done shot yeah it was
oh what oh [__]
that's all he do damn
it's calling it I love this genre shot
so much yeah what you got on my drink no
it's just straight up that's people Jesus
dang that was wonderful man come on smokers go
in if somebody comes Wilson and I ain't trying
to get involved with y'all you don't get involved
I'm Gonna Knock your ass out too make a choice
foreign
Mr Parker oh man come on
yeah ain't like you got [__] to do
tomorrow you don't have to go to work
won't take it I got a drink okay
you stimulate your mind you ain't got [__] to
do oh my God peer pressure is a hell of a thing
just reminds me of the good old days
what's gonna happen not gonna get a job
like a pro I gonna be supplying you
you're gonna be talking about my [__]
oh this is where it came from goodbye Felicia
what's up Craig what's up smokey nothing
what y'all smoking
let me borrow a joint you
need to borrow a job with
your broke ass always trying to smoke
up somebody's [__] pray bye Felicia
the birds kicking in I'll start tripping
Creek Chris Tucker is always bad
hold up
I gave my heartbeat man that's what
it's supposed to do you're funny looking
I don't do that gay [__] now this
is just like a hangout movie yeah
yeah it's smokey he's home what and she
said you wanted to hook up what's up
are you high huh are you high oh where'd you say
that because you look like you've been smoking
yeah I still look I still look out still looks hot
again for real Janet Jackson this
is before like Tinder smartphones
so he doesn't describe what you look like
she is a trip I know that's her sister one
time he grabbed me no yes grabbed me like this
for it I mean was it like this or was it like this
hey uh I got to go in here
in the back room real quick
that's such a hyping music
you know my homie want to hook up with you oh crap
what happened to you got bit in the
ass today son my stinking ass filthy
dog you should have seen it biggest dog
I've ever seen in my life and I turned
around to jump over the fence
the dog grab my ass oh my God
how your ass feel Mr get out of my house
and don't slam that door all right man
laughs
what you gonna do is it the drug
dealer yeah it's the drug dealer
I'm gonna be here 10 o'clock on the dot not 1003
not 10 36. if you ain't got my money or my bud I'm
killing you and him can I have my chili Fritos I
can't have [__] I'm close fat boy uh mama mama
hey we need to pay him hey crazy man let's
stick together I can't believe you got me
in the mix with this fool oh man put that
joint to your lip and make you smoke it
might as well it's Friday I'm gonna get
you high why you bringing up old [__]
can I go inside and get it hey come on
I would love to sit on this
front porch right right
oh [__] look where I guess oh oh no
oh yeah now oh you did that's messed up
that's just different from down the street
she was just just go in the house
look at that get your ass in the house
all right man I'm gonna go to crib
man my stomach hurt come back hi
well it just becomes like
a hard-hitting street drama
number one number two
you ain't gonna drop no thinking loads
here anybody drop this thing alone it's
gonna be me let's stop oh man I'm
we're the uh warped by this movie
it's like I'm strangely entranced by
this experience I've lived in and I'm
just like yeah this is such a weird hangout movie
you man when you're done I clean all
that [__] up for you for two dollars
two dollars you got some money about
two hundred dollars you gonna give me
you're slick don't come over
here ask me for some money
it's like comforting but the sad it is like
see I'ma tell them you ain't got nothing to
do with it I smoked up his weed imma face
the consequence if I get dealt with I get dealt
with Friday the Oscar moment yeah what's that for
protection this one makes you a
man you win some you lose some
but you live you live to
fight another day wow this is
we kept rewinding it kind of looked like you're
here but you can't really tell from the back
are you at oh it's cool
I've been wondering when I
explore this is so good um
why are you tripping Depot mess don't you give
him back his chain what chain yeah what changed
put your fists up man fight him lose
and I got mind control over Debo
he'd be like shut the [__] up
I be quiet but when he leaves I'll be talking
again remember grandma would give me that chain
this is a roller coaster
oh
my God
okay this neighborhood has to come together to
save smokey hey what's up with me I was in there
on the phone with Debbie and uh what's up Arena
we know who Rita is going to be here at 7 30.
that's my friend I'm triggered that's
Janet Jackson Janet Jackson The Girl
Debbie hooked me up with he about to get
catfished before catfishing was a thing oh
not a damn thing
we can kick it but I forgot I had to go pick
up my mom from work that's all right I'll take
you to get it ah she don't like a lot of
people with me when I go get it oh my God
look won't you go up the street and
get something to eat I know you hungry
yeah ate twice before I came God damn
why you woke me up with that fat ass bald head
girl oh Rita yeah Rita is not fat she's just
big bones ah talking about she look like Janet
Jackson oh no she didn't go there yeah [__] got
out of the car looking more like Freddie Jackson
don't laugh it ain't funny she was in Fresh Prince
oh okay yeah I was trying to figure it out
too Felicia [__] demo too could you mind
your own business or your mama is my
mama is in Vegas with her boyfriend
so y'all just Pauline up in here huh oh
[__] party over here fully shun him huh
oh disgusting oh it's so gross
foreign
just leave it there what are you doing
what what I'm getting in the
water oh yeah oh my God this guy
hey what the hell are you doing in here
hey be quiet it's got so suspenseful so fast just
when I was gonna get the money little crackhead
these they'll come running through the window
woke him up he's trying to beat his ass get
that man let's just go back over he probably still
sleep for real yeah you're breaking in though you
gonna be with me I got you man true friendship
this movie is about true friends yeah exactly
have him beat up the drug dealer guy huh
what's this can't catch me all right guys
too make his ass
hey um somebody uh hey smokey don't play dumb
you know I think we better stay in the house
why don't you sell the gun
yeah I literally saw anything
just smoking them Tweeds and everything
wearing the old clothes all half off
your ass what the hell's going on today
huh weeds man ain't nobody even out here
I don't even know why I'm tripping
if I want to mess with the Smoke Dog
[__] damn
for two hundred dollars yeah but
if you adjust for inflation it's
like four hundred dollars that's
awful hurry up hurry up hurry up
dude this guy's gonna get two hundred
dollars one two three you see him yeah
look at your face are you okay no look at your
face what you hit my sister like she was a man
some business going through my pants while
I was sleep my sister don't need to steal
nothing from your broke ass all right you lucky
I'm not a man otherwise I kick your ass myself
oh hell no uh-uh man that's a female
shut your little punk ass up looking
for a drop you like I did this [__]
and I ain't even trying to fight you Debo
bro no no you wanna fight me
because you're gonna build up
it's gonna do with that your
dad's gonna be disappointed
yeah put that gun down some I get knocked
out like your father used to whoa what what
Craig give me give me a guy
knock him out punch him foreign
oh you can beat him and take the 200.
oh [__]
that hurt my back looking at it
come on Craig told y'all JoJo
prank come on Craig come on
Craig fair enough come on man
oh holy [__]
yes Mr big shot let's go no guns but
bricks are okay yeah bricks are okay yes
that's what I'm talking about that's my dog
still a 200 we're good like all right Mom
you got knocked them
nice Grandmama gave me this chain nice
Felicia get in there
because I steal I don't kill
me oh I got his bike back I was just wondering
that maybe if you're feeling better than
that feeling better already
a long Friday laughs they've been
awake for like 14 hours I think
that's right did he just break the fourth
wall yeah he's done it a couple times why you
you know why I waste my time on your old
stupid ass anyway I don't know either
it's over [__] I got your money anyway
and you share that [__] yourself next time cause
I'm going to rehab I'm through with this [__]
character development we love it
I was just bullshitting and you know this
man Friday we should have watched it on
Friday it's Saturday I know like
goddamn morons we're such idiots
I I don't think there's a post-credit scene
salary I adventure to guess that it doesn't
set up the cinema of Friday too well there is
two more Fridays after this actually I think
there's there's not a Multiverse I think there's
next Friday and then yeah really that's what it's
called next Friday and then Friday after yeah I
think it's yeah I think you're right yeah Friday
After Next is so goes next Friday then Friday
After Next oh my God I don't think Chris Tucker
returns for the other ones why he was this he
was the moment you know what I mean he was the
moment I I know what you went to rehab that's
why oh yeah or they killed him off or something
I don't know what happened I'd be curious to find
out though damn this must be like massive ass hits
anyway not me realizing I dated someone like Smoky
not too long ago I was like huh did you really
listen desperate times either
grow your ass up man anyway
let's talk about it okay I thought that was um it
was so it was different than what I expected it
to be it took me a little we were like Sally it's
gonna be dark it's gonna be darker than I thought
it'd be like more than to rush hour I thought it'd
be more edgy and [__] like rush hour is more of
like a Hollywood script Punchy comedy film yeah
and and this felt like a an interesting like you
know crude rude sassy satire very a few locations
you know yeah it's like a hangout movie yeah and
I thought that was really cool that they just
like made a a really solid hangout movie with
these guys and it took like it took me a little
bit of time to like adjust to it because I was
under the impression might just be like some some
wacky comedy pretty much um but yeah it's got this
I'm like Dude Where's My Car yeah I was expecting
Dude Where's My Car yeah like a sketch comedy yeah
um but yeah it's got like a interesting direction
and you know I like the I like the crass humor uh
that it has and so yeah I mean it was it was it
was interesting because it seemed to carry this
like sometimes I decided to get like a little
serious insertion scenes obviously and it yeah
it would uh which like threw me off a little bit
because I was like where's the joke and then it
didn't come and I was like oh wow they go in there
I thought the ending would have more of a serious
part two you know what I mean yeah but yeah I
thought there'd be a little bit more of a perhaps
a serious but you got the girls though he got
the girl he actually wanted and I I feel like the
how do I put it I I think there's a bit of like an
interesting poignancy in this film where it seems
like there are some like real world like it's six
this came out when did it come out let me look it
up really fast 1995 95 that's right the year you
were born yeah I came out uh it came out in 1995
and it was it was it was sort of like having that
resonating um like real world things that a lot of
African-American neighborhoods had to deal with
still do and so so dealing with that throughout
but also finding like a sense of community by the
end of it all which I was like there's something
I kept saying I was like there's something
comforting about it I don't know whatever
yeah I I didn't I can't quite put my finger
on it either because about like 15-20 minutes
when I'm like I'm not really like cracking
up but I'm definitely like and interesting
I'm definitely interested in enjoying it and
I'm and I'm watching and I'm really just like
I I don't I couldn't I couldn't find the words it
took me a while but there's something that feels
like while wacky but also weirdly authentic
you know in a strange way definitely I feel
I feel like writing from experience but then
being able to add comedy comment the mood from
their experiences probably living in neighborhoods
like this yeah that's how I felt it was I mean
not to I feel dumb like a white person wearing a
[__] stop gun violence well it's not huge guns
um but like I lived in a really low income area
and I lived in neighborhoods like this in Florida
and it kind of weirdly reminded me as a kid of
like growing up with people like this and it was
kind of we had a blast all the time and there
was always weird neighborhood drama we'd all
as kids we'd be on our bikes like getting
into it and like doing stupid [__] and
um but I can't imagine like actually having that
much violence and trying to like just having it
be an everyday thing because we'd see stuff but
as kids but we were never like involved in it
um so I just it made me kind of feel a little
sad that this is definitely their reality a
lot at least that's what I'm assuming from the
writing like it it just the writing sounded very
authentic and just like I don't know I thought it
was if in that sense I'm just like I think it was
well done for uh us a smaller scale movie and for
something that they're probably you know drawing
from experience on I guess but making it funny and
yeah they also they managed to have it with the
the backdrop that weirdly has a a line of tragedy
and comedy but they also have it as a stoner
comedy and you know like ice cubing and Chris
Tucker they do have like they do have surprise
like there's such different you know your economy
tend to have a high energy low energy character
or more of the straight man and the high energy
wacky one and which there's always that duo with
friends there's like the the one that's like high
all the time and like you know got a lot going on
and there's like the chill like level-headed one
and it's like it's so accurate yeah friendships
and I think they have they have good but they both
bring a good energy to the screen and I also think
that uh yeah I mean in a lot of ways it's more of
Chris Tucker's show in here and he's really I'm
sorry he's not in the other ones really I don't
think so that's what I've been trying to find
out while we've been talking because I've been
looking I've been looking into it it was like
a good buddy comedy like I'm I feel like they
had really good chemistry it's hard to imagine
the next one without him not even having him in
it yeah yeah just his facial expressions alone
I'm gonna be like he's like the the person
in your head you know the things that you
want to say and the way you want to
react but you like have to polish
yourself down yeah yeah be that person
there's a weird sense of being a slice
of life kind of film to it I don't know
I feel like are we talking deeper about
the movie that's really just an offensive
hangout movie yeah because there are Parts
because it's it's simple but there's also
something admirable about like f Gary Gray's
Direction with this was at times so like because
yeah this is like he's eventually gone on to do
like massive freaking films but but here you
know it feels an incredibly low budget uh but
there were times where I thought he really
leaned into like certain genre tropes that
I thought were impressive and he he managed to
ring out a a with a movie that was like okay
so this is just like a like 30 minutes since
it was like oh this is just a movie about like
random instances of things that are happening on
a Friday night kind of all like tying at the end
yeah exactly that's what was impressive to me
it all like coalesced together by that and then
it and it got a little real worldy at times and
and it had a and had a sense of tension and I
did find as I was like what exactly is happening
in this movie it took me a while to adjust to it
and then even by the end with Ice Cube as Craig
when he does have that fight and he like arcs
into being a man like finally being able because
he's like he's 22. he's just a child at home and
then you're by the end of it he's like okay this
is setting him I don't know what the sequels do
but at the end of this it's like okay set an
amount of path to really be a man finally and
and so I was like oh there's actually even like a
good character article for this guy that I didn't
even really see coming so yeah I was surprising
it wasn't like I was cracking up for most of it
um no but it was entertaining through and through
not a dull moment for me yeah that's what I mean
like it because you're just kind of wondering why
everything is happening and I'm like why are why
all these characters are introducing it um you're
kind of like oh why did they put that in but I
think that in terms of characters this movie
was really rich in that in that sense because
um I feel like now movies like you know what
characters put there for like a specific reason
and I feel like I kind of missed when characters
just kind of existed for no other real reason
other than I don't know just just to be it's just
more realistic to me to just have people come in
and out that really have nothing to do without
me because I'm just like yeah that's real life
like honestly well it's like the hangout Vibe of
the neighborhood just they're chilling on their
porch and it just [__] just keeps happening in
the neighborhood and I'm like it's it is it is it
does bring that Community to life and it does
like what you were talking about with feeling
like they wrote from experiences like you you get
the vibe that okay this character is based off
someone they knew then this character is based
off someone they knew then and also the dad uh
John Witherspoon that's so funny he's so funny and
then he had such a great tender scene and I was
like Wow how'd they do this how'd they make it oh
he's a great actor because he went from being kind
of like ridiculous and you know like that kind of
Trope dad and then he actually had a real moment
with him where I was like damn like this got
deep but in a but you believed it it wasn't like
uh like the tone definitely went back to being
serious like I feel like the tone in this movie
you could tell when they shot certain scenes
like they nailed it I feel like but yeah they're
I felt like with the dad like what you said it
was believable because it didn't feel like this
isn't the same character all of a sudden you know
because he's so wacky and so sketch comedy like
um when he is just like vulgar and off-putting
and I feel like you know what's funny I was
thinking in the beginning the whole dynamic with
the whole family like in the very beginning I was
laughing to myself because I'm like this is like
real life and how like family bickers but you'll
never see that no offense like in a in a white
movie it's always like honey I made you this
really amazing breakfast and they're like sorry
Mom I'm gonna be late for school I'm like that
doesn't I've never had that happen in my life
and it's like you're always just like talking
[__] to each other but like you love each other
um and I feel like when white people write family
it's just like not like that at all but I feel
like that's just like more real the way they did
it is like way more realistic for like siblings
to like you know put each other down and [__]
but then they at the end of the day like they're
still gonna you know be there for them and stuff
so I I'm like that it just was like refreshing
to see that um and when when he was like oh he
didn't understand why his mom was like married
to his dad because he thinks his dad is like dumb
disgusting but then you have that really dark
deep moment between them and you're kind of
like okay that's like he's still a husband
he's still like a good dude and he's been
through [__] and especially with that line
when he's like oh I'm gonna beat you up like
your dad used to get beaten up like you kind of
understand why yeah his dad is the way he is and
yeah it's true I did say that at the beginning
and then the movie answered it for me actually
exactly actually brought it and did you said it
not him okay I was like yeah yeah uh no I've ever
said at the beginning like why would you marry him
like and yeah and then I I asked myself that every
time I see a lot of people and uh the villain
the Debo you just saw a Fifth Element didn't you
with John yeah yeah yeah we watched it together it
wasn't Debo the president in Fifth Element that's
where I saw him from because I was like looking at
him I was like I just saw him in something and I
couldn't figure it out because he looks out I feel
like he looked very different was that I think so
you need to look it up Tom Lister uh I think it's
I mean here is credited as uh I mean I don't know
if it goes by a Tiny Lister Tommy Lister Jr that's
who it is I mean he's been acting for like ages
you're right he wasn't well yeah he's got like
such a difference like 100 credits to his names
guys he's a great actor 220 credits to his name my
God good for him man wow I thought when they when
they had that moment sitting there and it was like
this beat and I thought they were just gonna look
at each other and like they were gonna try to get
him to beat up the the guy was asking for money
but he's also in uh The Dark Knight when uh with
the boats at the very end with choosing the boats
he takes the controller and throws it out the
the window do you remember that scene at all yes
no that was a really really really heartfelt
moment in that movie like a moment of humanity
imagine just having that booking that
you know what I mean yeah in the dark
night that's that's King [__] right there
this dude for him this dude has been acting
forever oh yeah and him and Chris Tucker
are both in Jackie and Tarantino's Jackie
Brown look at his IMDb right now this is
kind of crazy he's he was he was really
effective too because he did ride that great
line of like being funny but also being like
just scary like scary terrifying I think
the Jaws theme helped too yeah that's true
um yeah I don't know that was a ride that was
fun yeah it was this is like a movie you'd have
on like if you're like you know throughout the
day if you're just not really doing much and
you have this movie on and you're just like
hanging out with friends or something like
a little baked having a good little baked
I wasn't going to say it but it was implied
yes uh yeah that was that was a fun movie
and uh I thought it had a little bit more
poignancy than I expected but overall
it was like an interesting just I like
a good Slice of Life I mean usually a
slice of life's are like you know yeah
yeah they could be depending on what it is it
could be boring you made a good point though
I would have loved for him to uh have eaten
that cereal with the water and been like this
is amazing that's what I thought oh cereal when
you're baked is the best Fruity Pebbles man that's
my go-to fruity I was gonna say pretty bubble
I just got a like um a new face very expensive
like facial serum and it smells like Fruity
Pebbles and Fruit Loops okay that's interesting
I don't know if I want to smell someone's
face smelling like Fruity I think it's it's
to smell like Fruity Pebbles I did have a candy
rather smell like that than Felicia that's true
no we're so mean no but I laughed because like
she got super close to him she kept getting
close and he kept like moving away and it's
always people that smell or have bad breath
that get like so close to you like when I worked
retail um I don't know why they it's like almost
like they just know you're you're like not into
it fascinating Sally fascinating yeah there's
guys you can check out Sally's uh she
starts at Texas Chainsaw Massacre short film
I was in a Texas Chainsaw Massacre like on an
official fan film and um yeah I look disgusting
so check it out I feel like everyone on set was
like the DP was like now go lie you it's so gross
I was like thanks no no no it was good horror
movie it's it's the kind you look like you know
it's repulsive but that I will say I cut up my
legs we did a drone shot like running through
the cornfield and they didn't end up using it they
cut me out of it and oh it's just it's okay I mean
I know why they did it we have gone all over the
place here Breaking Down The Dark Knight salvation
I'll let you watch something if the fifth
element with John Where Are You Gonna you
know have a pretty cool conversation and
I'm like let's talk about Spaceballs and
Fridays too two very different Oddball quirky
comedies so but yeah guys follow Sally on our
YouTube channel and uh she's got some fun stuff
coming out and follow her on social media as well
she does not post bikini photos not anymore
I mean maybe I won't scattered maybe soon major
trouble once for do you remember that I remember
that I don't know why I like thought about
it the other day sounds like a joke and then
oh man remember that big fight I got it too oh
that was some neighborhood Friday [__] yeah
that's a big argument oh man that was so darling
oh man I feel like I made amends with that person
but I don't recall if I did now this is like
she was like five years ago so I don't remember
um five or six I don't think that person
no offense is like relevant to our lives
anymore like I don't give a [__] even if you
did Kathy I gotta I gotta resolve I gotta take
care of the dramas of my past you know
I I gotta tend to unresolved arguments
anyway she doesn't post those photos anymore
talking about it thank you all for single
now so so maybe I will I don't know that's
not going to be more modest don't don't lure
with that or maybe whatever helps you get more
followers are you being a dad right now are
you like don't post bikini photos I I mean
you can don't you know uh depends so you're like
an older brother you're like please I don't want
to see that why why would you what would be
the purpose of doing it is it to to get more
followers to to find to get an attractive guide
there really isn't I mean the guys in my DMs
and then it doesn't go anywhere you know so a
bikini pick has never gotten me anything really
no I get a [__] ton of likes it definitely
boosts my the algorithm you know like I know
why girls do it because it does get them like
more likes and followers but I'm like what is
that if it's not money I don't you know what
I mean that's true if you can't monetize your
body what's the point you're not giving me money
like and I'm not gonna make an only fan so sorry
about it all right guys thanks for being here
catch you all soon have a great Friday foreign